June marks the return of strange new
Worlds the hit series that has Star Trek
fans rediscovering their favorite final
frontier but before you warp back into
the show here are some important things
to know
in addition to the recent announcement
of the season premiere on June 15th more
information has been released about the
eagerly anticipated crossover episode
with the Animated Series Star Trek lower
decks it will be directed by Jonathan
Frakes best known as the next
generation's Will Riker Jack Quaid and
Tony Newsome who voice and sign Brad
boimler and Ensign Beckett Mariner will
feature in a live-action and animated
episode Anson Mount told Star Trek fans
at 2022's Comic-Con panel that the honor
Falls to me to announce that in season 2
of strange new worlds there will be a
crossover episode with lower decks he
also made a joke about his famously
quaffed character Captain Pike
[Music]
extremely buff two-dimensional version
of me
the season one finale of Star Trek's
strange new worlds was explosive with
Christopher Pike forced to accept the
consequences of trying to change his
future and the arrest of una chin Riley
his number one according to Anson Mount
Pike will be more relaxed in season two
now that his future is decided he told
Esquire his job now is to make every day
count as much as possible there's a lot
of freedom in that in addition we'll see
a new side of Spock with Ethan pack
telling TV Insider Spock gets to really
start to explore his human side and it
leads to a lot of I hope funny hijinks
so I'm really excited about that
bringing that comedic element to spock
there are also hints from Christina
Chong that her character LA on nunian
Singh May explore facets of her
personality with the actress hinting at
a dark side speaking at Comic-Con she
said who knows maybe we get to see a
version of LA on where she inherits more
of the other side of Khan with James T
Kirk finally introduced we can expect to
finally see the iconic friendship
between him and Spock begin to form as
well as Works time on the USS Farragut
showrunner Henry Alonso Myers told Trek
movie That season 2 keeps up what fans
enjoyed of season one and then some I
would also say in some ways it's
different we were trying to take what
worked and really amplify that and then
try to correct where we weren't happy
with it
most of the entire cast from season 1 is
expected to return which includes Anson
mountas captain pike Rebecca Romaine as
number one Ethan Peck as Spock Christina
Chong as LA on nunian Singh Celia Rose
Gooding as nyota Uhura Melissa Navia as
Lieutenant Erica Ortegas Jess Bush as
Nurse Christine Chapel and Babs olusa
mokun as Dr Joseph umbenga while Bruce
horak's Hammer died in season one
co-executive producer Davey Perez
alluded to his return as another
character telling the seventh rule that
horak's relationship with Trek is not
over we really love him and Star Trek
has a long tradition of reusing actors
Paul Wesley will return as Captain James
T Kirk as is Spock's betrothed to pring
Adelaide Kane is in at least one episode
but her role is largely unknown at this
point another addition is two-time Emmy
Award winner and oscar-nominated Legend
Carol Kane she plays pelia the new chief
of engineering who's described as highly
educated and intelligent and someone who
suffers no fools
between the chapel Spock to bring love
triangle and Captain Pike's encounter
with Old Flame allora the first season
of strange new worlds had plenty to
offer in the romance Department the
teaser trailer for season two hints that
Sparks will continue to fly perhaps in
some unexpected directions in addition
to a few knowing looks between Spock and
Chapel there appears to be a close-up of
a mere kiss between nurse chapel and Dr
umbenga the two medical officers have
shared a warm working relationship so
far in the series but could
circumstances push them closer together
meanwhile Commander una notices
something between Lieutenant Commander
La anunian Singh and visiting Commander
James T Kirk
[Music]
energy what making me sweat
um Kirk has a reputation as a lothario
so it's not surprising that the show
might tease his involvement in some kind
of fling but the prickly security Chief
LA on is a surprising choice for a
romance will on break out of her shell
to pursue the smooth talking Starfleet
Maverick
most of the recurring aliens in Star
Trek have been redesigned at least once
but no one's had as many controversial
facelifts as the franchise's most iconic
antagonists the Klingons originally
actors in dark makeup and glued on Fu
man shoes when they debuted in 1966 the
Klingons would adopt their famous
forehead ridges in 1979's Star Trek the
motion picture over the next 25 years
their designs would receive multiple
modifications and variants
they are Klingons
and it is a long story
we do not discuss it with Outsiders
when Star Trek Discovery premiered in
2017 the Klingons were given a prominent
role as well as a dramatically different
makeup and costume design rather than
sporting the long hair and bumpy
foreheads to which fans had become
accustomed these Klingons had hairless
ridged and elongated Heads This effort
to use modern advancements and makeup
effects to make the Klingons more alien
was loudly rejected by the fans this led
to a course correction in season two
giving Klingons their hair back while
retaining much of the new makeup since
then however the Klingons have been
notably absent from live-action Star
Trek wharf's role in season 3 of Star
Trek Picard was an exception his makeup
effects resembled those he wore during
the later years of his tenure on the
Next Generation and Deep Space Nine as
glimpsed in the teaser trailer the
Klingons will return in season 2 of
strange new worlds complete with the
prominent ribbed foreheads and luxurious
hair and beards that fans are used to
the makeup scene in the trailer is
definitely new but it's much closer to
the most popular image of the
space-faring Warriors they're also
apparently in a better mood than when we
last saw them toasting a cup of blood
wine with Mr Spock
the season 2 teaser trailer indicates
that Lieutenant Spock will soon get his
first opportunity to take command of the
USS Enterprise and one of the trailers
highlights the young science officer
sits in the big chair preparing to give
his first orders when wisecracking Helm
officer Lieutenant Ortegas primes him to
debut his own engage style catchphrase
Spock takes a moment before speaking
I would like the ship to go
now of course fans know that Spock will
eventually become much more comfortable
in a leadership role aboard the
Enterprise he becomes the ship's first
officer under James T Kirk in Star Trek
and eventually its captain in the Years
between the motion picture and the Wrath
of Khan Henry Alonzo Myers assured fans
in a 2022 interview with TV line that
Kirk and Spock will meet for the first
time during season two and that the show
Absolutely makes a big moment of it
season one of strange new Worlds
reintroduced the Gorn The Reptilian
antagonists who date back to the
original series but have rarely been
seen since in the new series The Gorn
are more brutal and terrifying they have
essentially become the Star Trek
equivalent of the Xenomorphs from Alien
they lay eggs inside their prey and
burst violently from their hosts bodies
killing everything in sight the episode
all those who wander leans hard into the
alien comparisons and it appears that
this trend will continue into season two
in the teaser trailer we see La on face
down an adult Gorn in a shot that
immediately calls to mind earlier moment
from David Fincher's alien 3. however
that doesn't mean that the Gorn will
only be depicted as mindless Monsters by
and large Star Trek avoids totally
dehumanizing its antagonists fans know
from their appearance in TOS that the
Gorn are a sentient species capable of
communication and reason this will not
be ignored in the new series speaking to
trekzone Anson Mount implied that the
Gorn who were essentially monsters in
season 1 would receive further thematic
exploration in The Following Season he
said is it possible that intelligence
can be so completely ripped apart from
any sense of communication or idealism
is there such a thing as a monster we go
down that exact Road
time travel has been a staple of Star
Trek since the very beginning with every
single spin-off dipping its toes into
the time stream at least once season one
of strange new worlds concluded with
Captain Pike visiting an alternate
future in which he avoids his fateful
training accident and remains in command
of the Enterprise for the events of the
original series it appears that season 2
will also feature at least one time
travel story of its own the final scene
of the strange new worlds season 2
trailer sees LA on and Kirk walking into
what appears to be a fast fashion
retailer in our 21st century Kirk
struggles to figure out the store's
revolving door though laan teases him
for it implying that we haven't done
away with turnstiles by the 23rd century
and Kirk is just being kind of clumsy
strange new worlds has been an
opportunity to delve deeper into a
handful of characters from the
franchise's early days who never got the
attention they deserved in the original
series Chief among those recovered
Treasures is nyota Uhura season one of
the new series finally filled out her
backstory revealing that she joined
Starfleet in search of a new home after
the tragic deaths of her parents and her
brother in a shuttle accident looking
for distance from her loss and a new
sense of purpose Uhura is still unsure
whether she wants to remain in the
service after her graduation from
Starfleet Academy
I
guess the truth is I'm not sure I'm
actually all that Starfleet
her experiences aboard the Enterprise
particularly her bond with chief
engineer hemmer encouraged her to stick
around but in the penultimate episode of
season 1 all those who wander hemmer is
killed in an encounter with the Gorn and
Uhura is Left Behind once again to mourn
and question her future preview clips
and interviews have implied that Cadet
Uhura will spend some of season 2
grappling with her feelings of loss and
abandonment at 2022's San Diego
Comic-Con Celia Rose Gooding described
Hammer as a father figure to Uhura and
his death is bound to reopen the very
wounds he helped her to heal one image
in the season 2 trailer of Uhura
standing next to the wreck of a
shuttlecraft could even depict her
revisiting her memories of the accident
that shattered her family
modern Star Trek series Relish in the
opportunity to revisit popular
characters from previous incarnations of
the franchise each of the shows in the
streaming era has taken place during a
different time period in the history of
the Star Trek universe this makes it
possible for just about any character in
the Canon to show up at some point
Strange New worlds is set during the
23rd Century about seven years before
TOS meaning that lots of familiar names
from the classic era can and have
cropped up on the show speaking to
inverse shortly after the season 1
finale co-show Runner Henry Alonso Myers
said that season 2 will see The Return
of more Legacy characters from the
original series era Myers declined to
offer any further details preferring to
keep these returns a surprise for fans
and there have been no additional hints
or reveals to the Press sends however we
think the smart money is on Spock's
half-brother cybach whose involvement in
future episodes was teased during season
one's the Serene Squall at the end of
that episode it's revealed that the
Vulcan criminal at the center of the
plot zavarius is actually Spock
half-brother he's portrayed as an
illogical Rebel Who currently resides in
a Vulcan Rehabilitation Center cybach is
the antagonist of the often reviled Star
Trek 5 the final frontier but strange
new worlds is the perfect opportunity to
revamp the character
thank you
[Music]